we got married at a rock club where we
both like it my name is Susan or okay
yes immediately the item oh my got it I
use it just like Oh like she loves
boulders
[Music]
hi everybody welcomed in the closet I'm
Jen that's Nikki today we have a very
special guest and we're gonna be talking
very special things her name is Cameron
Esposito when invite her in right now
Cameron if you'd like to join me in the
closet into the side door side door
that's it she's here a minute oh my nice
to meet you so nice to meet you too okay
you for having me in your closet that's
Nikki - no my name is Cameron Esposito
I'm a stand-up comic this is my jacket
the pronouns are she and her you wanted
to come on to talk about and get to know
people that are feeling kind of scared
and sad in this pretty scary and sad
time yeah that's right I knew that I was
feeling freaked out by the election how
are you feeling I am okay I sort of was
in a really bad place as a functioning
human it's kind of like I can go out and
go to my job and then also being like
okay like sometimes it gets really
overwhelming and I get freaked out and I
need to be a real punch bowl well for me
something that I do to deal with stress
is like a work which is great and it's
also a problem so I'm also trying to
like do the things that are not work
it's healthcare stuff can you just tell
us a little bit more about self-care
because I think that's something people
know is something they should do but
maybe have a hard time doing it
practically so it's gonna be different
for everybody I really believe in
therapy for me because it's like a safe
space that you can talk to somebody that
isn't a pal and isn't a co-worker
fitness is something that really hosts
moving my body is like something that
really fit really I just mean like here
in LA it's really easy to go on a hike
cuz it's warm right now it's like free
so you could just go there or having a
dog is the thing that yeah
cuz petting a dog is nice it's amazing
well I was tiny eight pounds awawa oh my
gosh yesterday eight mere plugs Oh is he
okay he's okay he barked it
well retardant specifically about queer
folks yeah I think something that helps
is no you're not alone what I did do is
there are a lot of like online groups
like there are forums there are like
queer websites that have like message
boards as like silly as it sounds when I
was 18 I genuinely counted like people
that I knew through usernames as my
friends because we don't think it's
silly at all yeah I feel like an 18 year
old little like scaredy cat it was like
these are the people that I can count on
to protect me and talk to cuz you might
not even have queer people in your
family you might not have queer friends
that you're super close to some stuff
you can do is like read books with queer
characters watch movies with queer
characters and hopefully like queer
characters that have positive things
happen in your life that sort of make it
throughout the show yeah I've seen the
kissing scenes from shows but you
haven't seen the shows like that's
amazing yeah okay so I refill you I've
watched entire sewer lines on YouTube
yes well you know mate for anyone who's
my favorite I thought that what was
going on in the 100 was really great but
floors really great are you red head do
you like bread a bread wait what is a
breadhead do you love bread bread yes
the food you guys talking about bread
though yeah yeah like bread I don't know
that I need too much to like sama bread
head more of like a Greek yogurt head
smoker Cameron yes we like to do this
thing or we do like rapid fire fast
questions just answer as quick as you
can
okay ready yes okay favourite snapchat
filter daughter daughters Oh least
favorite pizza topping
nothing really Wow every piece is
delicious will you ever not have a side
mullet I don't know okay would you
rather live in a world without cheese or
without chocolate chocolate who killed
Jenny Schecter
show time fair we should rather hang out
with Tegan and Sara or Jenn and Nikki no
no it's a five five seat table rather
okay okay oh that's so can you set that
up that'd be great yeah I totally could
great dope would you rather ride a
ferris wheel with Jenner would Nikki
neither afraid of heights oh okay who
would you rather adopt Jenner Nikki no
I'm looking for like a bunch of kids so
both yeah you can't go to Ferris wheel
okay wait what a really great rapid fire
successful rapid fire anything you'd
like to say to the people of the closet
you know reach out to me let's chat on
Twitter where I'm at Cameron Esposito
yeah or come see me in Los Angeles or I
tour a lot I will do my best to keep my
shows a safe place for queer folks is it
time for us to leave the closet looks
likes it to the side door we'll go this
way
okay thank you so thank you for having
me this is how you get Wow I dunno music
you guys
[Music]